splinter cell is back ubisoft toronto
has begun work on a remake of sam
fisher's most classic operations and
with the series return on the horizon
it's the perfect time to look back at
the game that started it all
what the hell i'm going to ask you some
questions when i think you're lying i'll
do this i who do you work for splinter
cell launched back in 2002 a time when
ubisoft was best known as the company
that made rayman a bright and colorful
platformer splinter cell was not that
it was a dark and serious stealth action
game that favored slow methodical
movements over frantic action
and no one was quite sure how fans would
react maybe it's better if i didn't see
anything to find out more about the
development of that first game and the
lasting effects it had we spoke to some
of the folks that helped launch the
original splinter cell and some that are
helping to bring it back
sam fisher i can't believe you beat me
here i'd like to be early very first
time we really understood that we had a
hit in our hands is i guess when we were
talking to microsoft like we had that
feeling that good feeling but it wasn't
validated by anything and we never had a
hit before it's not like not a big one
like that
when microsoft came to us and looked at
it
they knew also something was up and they
were considering it for their e3
showcase at the time for showing up the
xbox
and it was super scary for us because
we're like how are people going to react
we don't know because it's very dark is
it going to come through nicely on the
screen is it going to show off its
colors
the feedback we received from e3 was so
incredible so it just gave us give us a
huge push to uh to get things done and
get this game to the level of the
expectations probably for e3 and for our
competitors and for
um you know for for players at large it
probably came out of nowhere there was
this whole
who who is ubisoft it was
a transformation of what ubisoft could
do and how they were regarded that was
very special because at that time at
ubisoft montreal
we were producing games but we were not
in a aaa mindset at that time and this
game became somehow a great inspiration
from the teams and from that moment uh
when split yourself did release with a
very cool feedback and nice reviews and
nice popularity as well this this has
been an incredible trigger for the whole
studio to reach for this level of
achievement for other games but what
exactly was it that drew in audiences at
that e3 what did splinter cell do that
set it apart from the crowd the answer
as it turns out was pretty black and
white light shadow
it's instantly relatable and instantly
something that you know how to play with
people paid attention because they have
never seen such amazing visuals at first
that whole shadow and light was
beautiful and it was giving a dimension
that they had never played with and it
had to do with the the xbox and the
ability of the xbox to render these
dynamic lights with dynamic shadows and
dynamic real-time shadows and um and it
was really the ambition of the team
uh early on to to push the the visual
fidelity of the game
as far as we could the way art and level
design had to work together
to deal with you know
how dynamic lights would affect the
gameplay as well as the visuals was
probably one of the biggest challenges
of development it was one of those times
where a game came out and just really
had a brilliant presentation
that was so critical for the actual
design itself so you can only imagine
how exciting that would have been for
the team the first time we saw the you
know the fish tanks that you could you
know you could shoot the fish tanks and
the water would lower down with the the
stream and down to the level of the
bullet hole and then it would stop and
you know you could keep shooting it and
lowering it little tweaks like that
little little surprises that that you
know people just found the time and the
energy to put in to add the polish and
the care to the game uh that was great
remember thinking to myself you know i
was super blown away by the tech
advances that were part of that game the
stencil shadows and the moving cloth and
you know the thermal goggles and all of
the stuff and i just remember thinking
to myself you know
how that was even possible at the time
visually it was amazing you know the
light effects were remarkable ahead of
anything else that was being done at the
time
but it was even more than that
the use and exploitation of light and
shadow set splinter cell apart from its
competitors but it would take more than
that to deliver on the development
team's promise
a promise they felt so strongly about
they put it right on the box art stealth
action redefined was
born out of the fact that this was it
was this was a challenge to
the god of tactical espionage action
which was metal gear solid it
was really the mission that splint cell
set out for itself it was okay if we're
going to take espionage if we're going
to take stealth action how are we going
to position that in a way that
fits the tom clancy brand values as well
we had
rainbow six redstone was working on
ghost recon
those were obvious on plenty games but
splinter cell came from montreal
and montreal wasn't working on tom
clancy at the time
and when we looked at it we looked at
the fantasy we looked at
the realism
and the techno thriller aspect of it we
figured that we perfectly fit under tom
clancy back then there was a lot of you
know
a lot of games that were very kind of
heavy on just shoot kill be done that's
how you get through these situations um
made you slow down and made you think it
made you kind of try to understand the
threats that were ahead of you and it
layered all of those features together
and it rewarded players for thinking
differently for for being a bit more
kind of patient with you know the way
that they chose to solve those
situations the idea of being the one who
can make the difference who can go into
those places that no one's
supposed to be able to go to and do what
no one's supposed to be able to do
that's an incredibly powerful fantasy
and it's a lot of fun to be that person
we used an actor that was a recognized
person that was new at the time anybody
have a line back to third action
what the hell's going on nicolas just
declared war on the us what
now it's something that a lot of people
do a lot of game publishers it's kind of
normal but at the time it wasn't
and we really looked at it like first it
was a clancy brand so we looked at it
like something bigger than just a video
game marketed it that way and created a
persona sam's a great character
um he's smart he's funny he's fast he
does what he can do
with a minimum of waist he's a high
speed low drag
and he's just an incredibly fun
character to play while sam is
unequivocally the star of the splinter
cell franchise let's be honest he'd get
nowhere without his signature night
vision goggles
not only are they an essential tool in
sam's arsenal they're the symbol of the
entire franchise
those three green dots and that iconic
sound
yup that sound is enough to know exactly
what game you're dealing with the sound
came in very late and i think that
we didn't realize how important
and valuable it was until someone said
you know we really got to have a much
more iconic sound in here somewhere and
it had this kind of very military uh
feel to it we were trying to create
something that felt very realistic and
modern and
you know just because of the speed at
which technology moves it kind of became
its own thing in
in time and it adhered to sort of the
genuineness of it and and kind of stuck
19 years ago splinter cell put ubisoft
on the map and change the landscape for
stealth action games across the industry
now thanks to the upcoming remake a
brand new generation can experience the
best splinter cell has to offer
for future updates on the splinter cell
remake follow this channel and visit us
at news.uesoft.com
you